if you said there is no good form of
blackness none and don't ever try to
stop being black because you can't you
can't get out of it we'd go wow
that's a racist that's a big racist
right there well it's racist when they
do it about white people as well if you
took what is now said about white people
in america britain and elsewhere and
said it about any other group you would
be regarded rightly as a racist
douglas murray look at the show great to
be with you and great to be with you in
person for the first time it's been too
long since you've been on the show but
this is our first time in person when
was it last on two years ago ish
paperback of madness of crowds that's
right and the world's only got better oh
it's so much better so we've got a
couple of hours today and hopefully
we'll go through some stuff that maybe
you haven't spoken about before at the
end but
first there is some more
pressing news as you are aware
dumbledore is a proud member of the lgbt
community
but
as you may not be aware he is not
allowed to be his true self in china did
you see this no
let me tell you about i mean dumbledore
kept coming out
he came out more times than sam smith
so references to a gay relationship were
edited out of fantastic beasts the
secrets of dumbledore by warner brothers
for the film's release in china
as a studio we're committed to
safeguarding the integrity of every film
we release and that extends to the
circumstances that necessitate making
nuanced cuts in order to respond
sensitively to a variety of in-market
factors warner brothers said in a
statement to variety our hope is to
release the features worldwide as
released by their creators but
historically we have faced small edits
made in local markets
how gay was dumbledore in six seconds of
dialogue
what is it like
it's dialogue it's time oh it's dialogue
yeah it's not a full frontal scene come
on it's a film for children but my point
is that uh he said something to this guy
about how i used to love you or
something like that
and it's been cut
now we saw
harry potter on stage in new york with
jordan and tammy peterson only a couple
months ago
and if i remember rightly there was some
very slight illusion to gain us there
yeah the whole thing was homoerotic
i wouldn't agree with you there i i
thought there were lots of it was just
charming but the the no
there was some reference to it
uh didn't because i mean we don't i know
this is potterology but i thought
jk rowling only said that dumbledore was
gay laughed the whole franchise had been
in 2009
she posthumously brought stomachs mostly
outed
and yeah so richard harry's who died had
no idea he was playing a gay character
no which would have probably influenced
the role massively changed uh yeah the
point just being that
hollywood yeah hollywood to florida is
we say gay yeah yeah but hollywood to
china is we'll say whatever you want
please take our money beautiful isn't it
yeah it's beautiful well i mean i've i
just have unending contempt for these
people as you probably guessed
and uh the contempt is based on a lot of
things but one is the way in which these
sorts of
entertainment hon shows and so on always
they just their idea of bravery is
poking at empty hornets nests and
whenever they find a real hornet's nest
they just run a million miles
and that's why they're perfectly willing
to weirdly melt down
over florida and to santas and
a bill which is totally reasonable in my
view
to
not like tell three-year-olds
that they might wake up the next morning
in a different sex like that's
i don't think there's anything wrong
with
not teaching kindergarten as crazy
hundred gender two-spirit ideology which
was come up with about yesterday and
which they're still trying to work on to
make make any sense at all which it
never will
it's it's just completely typical the
same people who have a meltdown about
that happening
and attack florida
uh will be totally silent when the
communist party china expects different
rules
that's that's one of the ways in which
the 21st century could go
you know
there's of course of course we don't
upset you sir
did you see that a trans author wrote a
horror novel in which jk rowling is
burned alive by a trans woman
i didn't but you're missing out on
everything i haven't even read that book
no it sounds like nobody has i don't
know i don't know anymore i don't know
if it's yet to come out but what i do
know is that the secrets of dumbledore
had a 9.7 million dollar
first weekend in china which meant that
two out of every three people at the
cinema
was going to see
that film in china just tighten this in
a little bit
that's
that's uh
well
the rules are different there aren't
they and the cynical corporations
realize that
and uh
either none of it surprises me at all
um
this is how hollywood and other
companies operate
as i say they they pretend to be very
very brave they give each other rewards
for bravery they they meet up and slap
each other on the back for bravery they
talk about human rights in florida and
lots of things like that and then they
um just of course they do this in china
it's like ricky gervais said in the
golden globes other the other year you
know is if isis set up a streaming
service these people would run to it you
know i mean of course they would they'd
work for it if the cash came in i mean
uh look at all these companies apple
they're all such damn cynics they all
know how to play this sort of virtue
signaling thing in america and totally
different rules abroad it's always been
like that it's always been like that
um but i i am slightly amused by this
meltdown about the texas thing did you
see james saki the other day she cried
she cried
she said i'm just become very emotional
about what's happening in florida
because people are mean
well i mean
i don't know i mean maybe she's just
trying to make sure her job at msnbc is
secure
uh because if you express that amount of
sentimentality and stupidity then
you're almost certain to keep a job at
msnbc she could have got a golden globe
for the performance
it was do you think she believes it i
don't know i think if you wind
themselves up about this stuff
they wind themselves up about issues
that are
that are
just not relevant just the line between
persona performance and identity kind of
begins to get blurred i mean
obviously the white house spokesperson
is obviously a she's a smart woman
she must know that the florida bill in
question doesn't say what she's
pretending it says isn't gonna do what
she's pretending it'll do she must know
that i mean she's not stupid very stupid
people who aren't informed might believe
that that actually governor ron desantis
has decided that you're not allowed to
say the word gay in florida
uh but
i don't believe that somebody who's well
informed could think that so they
they whip themselves up on on things
that don't hurt them you know have you
ever used your gay privilege card
well on other gay men probably
i mean i just how much do you want to
know
it's kind of an intrusive question uh um
uh
what do you mean
is there not some sort of privilege it's
like
a free extra shot at starbucks or
whatever what do you get never no never
that um
uh
i think i know what you're getting at uh
does it work are there things i'm able
to say and do that a straight person
wouldn't yes
no
that would be the case if i was very
left-wing
or remotely left-wing
for sure
um but uh since i'm i've not got the
correct views
so you're basically straight
i'm i'm an honorary straight if not
worse i'm even worse straight
sexual
it's that bad chris
it's that disgusting and reprehensible
that
my views have ungained me
and i don't have a minority card
uh that is actually the case
uh it honestly is it's the same with
women right wing women and not really
women they have their woman card taken
away
uh anyone who's right-wing and gay isn't
actually gay they had that gay card
taken away and so on um
and i just said that occasionally i hear
people saying oh well douglas only gets
away with sayings and stuff he's saying
he's gay
i think they they don't really
understand that's not the case um i say
what i think and i defend it
pretty vigorously i think usually
and uh
i've never felt that i've had any extra
leeway because i happen to be gay partly
because it's something i don't talk
about very much because i don't think
it's very interesting and i don't want
to bang on about uninteresting things
but um but also because i i just i i i
don't believe in i
may have said this to you before in
private or in public but i don't believe
in the speaking as a
prefix i mean i just don't believe in
that and even before i could identify
what i didn't like about it i didn't
like it i didn't like the sort of person
who stood up and say um so my parents
were from peru and honduras and i am a
bisexual
i don't care get to the point
you know doesn't matter to me
stop it
um and people only ever did it if they
had traits that they thought meant that
they should grab the microphone
is there not some validity to
the experience that everybody has which
gives them a unique perspective on the
world yeah but that's endless
but everyone has that everyone's got a
unique perspective
goddammit i mean every person in the
world has a unique perspective
identical twins each have unique
perspectives from each other
that's not a very interesting
observation
i mean it's
we all have a unique perspective now you
know is a person who has been oppressed
in some way have they got a particularly
interesting perspective well on their
oppression sure and on subjects relating
to it but not on anything else
um
and i shouldn't take your advice on
accounting or
macroeconomics or something they're
definitely not
running around a million miles and i'm
trying to give you financially speaking
as a gay man yeah speaking as a gay man
you need to invest in isis i mean
all that sort of ridiculous validity
seeking uh i'm not in favor of but no i
suppose there are some people who
who
think that i
get away with saying certain of the
things i do about highly contentious
issues for some
they try to find some reason for it but
it's definitely not because of the fact
i haven't been gay because they say in
my own experience it's never been
anything i've benefited from
career-wise certainly hasn't
occasionally been something i've
suffered for in a certain to a certain
extent all i don't really like to think
in those terms i certainly don't like to
moan
which makes me an unusual figure in this
era of course did you see that the libs
of tick-tock creator got doxxed by
taylor lorenz oh yeah so disgusting i
loved libs of tiktok i mean we wouldn't
know about these maniacs i think
otherwise and i wouldn't sit on tiktok
watching what a teacher from minnesota
was saying about you know their gender
pronouns otherwise there's not quite
enough time in the day and uh and so
libs of tick tock did a great service
um and uh yeah taylor ends of the
washington post
that's just such disgusting baby long
article do you read it no i didn't read
the whole art long article serious yeah
i wish they'd ever looked at hunter
biden's laptop story a similar length
um
i mean corruption in the first family um
would strike me as being a much more
interesting subject than who runs libs
of tick tock
but then you know
washington pose has its own priorities
but taylor lorenz is someone who broke
down crying on msnbc not long ago
talking about online harassment
yeah all these people
bullies who whenever they've finished
bullying people
pretend to be a victim
whenever they get caught out they cry
um
the kathy newman phenomenon you know
bully somebody and then when you're
caught out behaving badly you present
yourself as a victim
nice
nice uh turnaround there very very
common so i think it's julie burchie who
coined the term cry bullies for these
people
uh cry bullies is a great term for our
era what do you mean by that cry bullies
are people who who go around bullying of
them and then um when they're caught or
in any way criticized cry
um just immediately turn themselves into
the victim everyone knows this from
children i mean there's a certain type
of child who does that and they should
be slapped or you know in a country or
allowed to slap a child um
or you know otherwise
you know disciplined to not behave like
that
uh
you know
these are sort of grown up eric
cartman's uh maybe not even growing up
those eric cartman like figures but
they're horrible bullies and nasty
people who when it's not going for them
go wow wow what do you think is the
problem with libs of tick tock as a as a
channel is it because it's just bringing
attention to things that the left would
rather people not see it's not it's just
left him it's just this is what
i mean i don't look at tick tock
um
and by the way i think it's a highly
unstable platform and obviously it's
chinese communist party direct
brainwashing slowly i did one video at
the time yeah all those things
and um
uh so so yeah obviously um you know
these teachers and others who
say these ridiculous outlandish things
there was one who even said she was a
witch did you see that one no there were
some teachers like you know i'm a witch
and i told the students and they i had
questions and that was that was fine i'd
say
make it a bit harder for us i mean you
know
to actually say i also practice
witchcraft or something strong as being
no
it seems to me like it's a warning shot
to any future potential
people that would consider doing the
same sort of thing because yeah you know
if someone posts something on tick tock
you're not not doing it to get attention
the whole reason that you're doing it is
to get
attention but maybe not by six hundred
thousand people on a twitter account
yeah yeah they don't they want to be
famous they don't want to be infamous
um
and uh
once something highlights it to a group
they would never have got to otherwise
who don't see it favorably it becomes a
different thing of course
um
i mean it's a form of that that thing in
the area of the context collapse
phenomenon that occurs with
social media all the time you know
context collapse being when the
an out group discovers an in-group's
discussion and doesn't view it what's an
example of that oh uh
um
banter between friends on texts for
instance
where a group of guys banter about stuff
and including bad taste stuff
joking about girls or whatever
somebody leaks it and an out group
discovers it and thinks
how disgusting the way these men talk
about women durham university got popped
for this a couple of years ago uh for uh
there's i mean people are sort of wise
up to now but yeah um
right rugby teams quite often you know
get done over for it um
[Music]
an out group discovers an in-group
discussion and
you know it's understandable that
that um
that that happens in our era because
everybody has access to the click of a
few buttons to expose an in-group's
discussion
and it's really hard sometimes to
discover what the context would be of a
particular discussion
um so i mean that is something that goes
on all the time at the moment but
uh
but libs of tick tock is simply
exposing what an in-group was hoping to
be able to say to to itself and it's
been discovered by an out group
but the out group really doesn't like it
because it's teachers you know and
things like that it's like
if if it's just we i mean there's that
one person on libs of tick tock i've
seen several times is a totally deranged
individual a man who dresses as a woman
and says he's trans and uh and and i had
a lipstick and like a hairy chest and
and like he says you know
um
yeah he he can't understand why people
don't think he's a woman and call him
sir and things you know i guess it's a
fact you got a hairy chest and yeah look
like a dude
um that's the problem i'd have thought
you know and uh but there's like this
this particular guy that he's like comes
back repeatedly like he's on one of them
he's like you will respect us
you will respect us and go i don't want
that person anywhere near
members of the public
uh it's really interesting to discover
those people
but but
it's just but what the washington post
did was it was was basically a
punishment beating
on the woman who who runs the libs of
tick tocks a punishment beating and a
warning to others well the editor said
that it was completely in line with the
journalistic standards at the washington
post well that's true but they amended
the article to remove her
real estate license that's right because
that heard doxxer did you know that
there's another online influencer with
the same name as the person that founded
libs of tiktok who's that the fallout
from this has been so hard that a person
that isn't the person that runs it but
has the same name has also been getting
harassed online
doesn't surprise me at all it doesn't
surprise me at all because taylor lorenz
turned up at that lady's house yeah yeah
yeah there's a video sorry there's a
photo of her standing at the door yeah
through the sort of she's just a really
nasty piece of work chloe it seems like
it's not the first thing that you know
this is the first time i've been
introduced to her um lots of people uh
in america
in media knew about her thought she was
a kind of rogue unpleasant bad operator
and um
this has just proven that i mean i mean
of course
it's vile behavior and as i say i mean
there's so much that's important to to
write about and
in america of all places
so many stories such a rich environment
for real investigative writing and
journalism
and uh to be going and exposing the
identities of
citizens
who are reposting things from tick tock
would strike me as being a very strange
journalistic priority
um but don't forget
truth dies in darkness
as the washington post tagline says
truth dies in darkness
so
their view of themselves of the
washington post is that absolutely
our democracy would not run
the world might not be free
unless they can docks take lives of
tick-tock so
that's there
okay so new book
indeed we're in the west hiding a can of
diet dr pepper who we both want to be
sponsored by if there's a if there's any
chance responsibility
doctor diet dr pepper i would welcome it
be my first sponsorship deal i promise
to carry it around all the time we know
that it's a legitimate love but
new book very good congratulations
on it uh
how has the west been
coaxed into hating itself
oh by all sorts of means um but the
first thing is just to establish that it
has that
i call it the war on the west because it
seems to me that everything that's
western everything that's
of the west is is in the process of
being assaulted
and uh insulted and demeaned and
diminished and um the rest of the world
does not put itself through this um
there are lots of forms of
anti-westernism which are
foreign you know there's
russia and andy western and there's
chinese anti-western there's a middle
eastern anti-westernism
all these are interesting but the
the most interesting one is um western
anti-westernism and that's really what
i'm writing about the way in which the
west has done itself over by
demeaning and diminishing itself and
attacking its own history attacking its
own heroes bringing down its own heroes
destroying its own path the past
carrying out iconoclastic attacks on its
heroes and founders
insulting the majority population the
white population so there is this
strange war on white people in our day
which a lot of people even just hearing
that phrase go you know worry but it's
absolutely the case racism in our day is
rightly deemed to be totally
impermissible
in the public square with one exception
which is white people about whom you can
say absolutely anything now
and people do and i give a remorseless
number of examples in the book i mean
if if any group of people if if you took
what is now said about white people in
america britain and elsewhere and said
it about any other group
you would be regarded rightly as a
racist in several a lot of countries
you'd be locked up for hate speech
but this is now not just normal rhetoric
but instilled and installed
in every area of government
in countries including britain and the
united states
it's instilled through the media
through academics
through the military through absolutely
every level of our societies
uh
white people are seen as being a problem
and
a problem
for whom a remedy must be found
now of course some of the maniacs who
have been pushing this like robin
d'angelo who herself is white and of
course the author of white fragility
which sold about half a million copies
after the death of george floyd
um
says there is no good form of being
white
no good form of being white
and
there's a rider
you also can't escape it
you can't escape it
so you can't like shift to another
racial group you can't identify as not
being white if you're white
she doesn't know what it is
and i don't think anyone really does
it's a very weird category to even talk
about people in these contexts
you know but
if you said that about any other group
of people if you said there is no good
form of blackness
none
and
don't ever try to stop being black
because you can't you can't get out of
it
we'd go wow
that's a racist
that's a big racist right there
well it's racist when they do it about
white people as well
the talk of white privilege has become a
racist trope quite clearly
uh the talk of white tears
white female tears try that any other
way black tears black female tears
oh she's just crying black tears oh
you'd say that's a that's a racist
uh so it is when they say white tears
about white rage when the ones that
they've um in this attempt to
pathologize being white
they've come up with most recently
particularly the wake of january the
sixth white rage uh no less a figure
than general milley the chairman of
joint chiefs of staff in the us
testifying for congress
addressed the issue of so-called white
rage said i want to learn about white
rage i want to find out what it is
let's try the other way around one more
time black rage
let's look into it
oh you'd say that doesn't sound like a
very nice thing to do why don't we just
talk about rage in general
white rage black rage
only one of those is a permissible thing
to talk about only one of those you'd
catch the channel of joint use of staff
using before congress where does this
asymmetry come from then is it because
white people are seen to it's always
punching up toward white people is it
this
current trend that we have toward
anti-westernism
colonialist imperialists reparations
need to come from the past and that
white people are
and that skin color is a representation
of that as an ideology or as a like the
modern day
tip of the spear of
of that history i think it's an attempt
to um
rectify a historic wrong and a wildly
misguided attempt at it
so i mean i think we talked about this
when we talked about the matters of
crowds we talked about the fact that
there's a there's such a thing as an
over correction in social issues you
know nobody denies that women
historically were not able to make the
same life choices as men were able to
make they didn't have as much freedom in
in general
um they didn't and so if you want to
make up for that historic wrong
the obvious thing to do is just make
everyone equal
a certain type of person says no we we
can make up it faster by punishing men
for a time
uh nobody can deny that gay people
historically were not treated equally as
straight people
uh there's a type of person who says
let's attack the heterosexuals for a bit
um instead of saying why don't we just
have equality
um in the same way
nobody with any sense would be able to
deny that historically
racism has existed in countries
of the west as it has in all countries
it's a very very ugly human instinct one
of the worst
uh and it exists in it it exists in
particular american society exists still
there are still pockets of racism in
america not not
legitimate or in any way mainstream but
but there are some people who will hold
racist views and
um but they're all on the margins
uh
nevertheless you can't deny that
historically america has been a white
dominated country in which black people
were oppressed for a very long time
until not that long ago
what do you want to do to make up for
that again you have the same options as
you have women other minority issues you
can decide to go for equality or you can
decide to overdo it for a bit
uh over correct and the over-correction
in race is let's beat up on the white
people for a bit
so one of the great race hustlers of our
day in america is a man who calls
himself ibrahim x kendi
partly to give himself a sort of malcolm
x vibe
and um
he wrote a book called how to be an
anti-racist
uh which is very very popular book in
america it's flooded everywhere
there's also a very slightly less
grown-up version called anti-racist baby
which he explains among other things for
two-year-olds that you should talk to
your two-year-olds about the fact that
policies not people are the problem
i don't know if you haven't met a
two-year-old but
they very rarely talk policy issues in
my view
my experience
um anyhow abram makes candy as he calls
himself
says completely openly in how to be an
anti-racist i quoted in the book he says
the answer to past
prejudice is present prejudice the
answer to past inequalities is present
inequalities you must you must you must
rectify historic wrongs by committing
wrongs in the present
is is his message what's wrong with that
what's wrong with that message
well
um
first of all it's uh you punish people
who look like people who did a bad thing
in the past
on behalf of people who look like people
to whom a bad thing was done
you're not even dealing with victim and
uh and oppressor
you're you're you're dealing with people
who look like perpetrators of the past
and people who look like victims of the
past so that's the first thing
second thing is it's not going to work
and i'll tell you one reason why it's
not going to work in particular which is
that um
that this would be very hard to do if
you're dealing with a minority group and
i think if you said to any minority
you're
you're really scummy and worthless and
historically you're the only people
who've ever done anything wrong and no
one else has and you know so on and you
should think badly of yourself and you
should be locked in this bad identity
forever and never get out of it
i think if you did that to a minority
group it'd be unlikely you could
persuade them into this mindset
try doing that with a majority group
i think you're doomed to fade i hope
they're doomed to fail i think they're
pretty confident they're doomed to
failure
um
i don't think it'll it'll work but it
seems like it's being pretty widely
accepted at the moment there doesn't
seem to be a massive amount of pushback
that's right um
i certainly get
you know when when you were
using examples earlier on of flipping
the language around to talk about black
rage or black tears or blackness that
you can't get rid of that makes me
cringe inside in a way that whiteness
doesn't
because i feel like it's i've just
become so used to
hearing that
terminology
use that
i don't think twice about it yeah well i
mean um
uh
in the early 2000s the uh filmmaker
michael moore wrote a book called stupid
white man
which i reference in my book i remember
it very well i remember thinking even
then in 2000 or so
oh i'm not sure that michael moore could
write a book called stupid black man
where there's a chapter in his book
called blame whitey i wouldn't have
thought you could do the opposite as a
chapter if
mr moore
uh he yeah he says in that book um white
if show me any problem in the world and
i can point you to white people being
behind it
uh
mr moore has not seen very much of the
world if he thinks that
um
but yeah it's been prominent throughout
our adult lives it's been growing
ahead of steam
it's um and it's now basically
acceptable and to hell with it the
time's got to be called on it it's a
vicious vicious thing
um and it's not just the fact it's not
the anti-whiteness which is just a very
very ugly prejudice it's that it's being
done as a way to attack people in the
west
and attack everything about the west and
that's why in the book as you know i go
through the war on white people the war
on western history
the war on western um religion including
philosophy and the war on western
culture whereby the same remorseless
attack the same remorseless allegations
of racism about everything
run through absolutely everything in the
culture explain to me how it is that
that gets accepted though you know
you're talking about the fact that you
have this majority it's it's a
a critique made of the the largest group
of people within the community it is
trying to critique
and yet it seems to have
been
i mean
here's the thing though i think that it
it's been accepted perhaps by
um media organizations and by book
publishers and by authors um but on an
individual level when you speak to most
people i think they would say oh this
kind of feels a little bit icky yeah i i
don't understand
how that's been allowed to occur with
that
because there's enormous um
everything i'm saying in this book and a
lot of what i'm saying to you now
um most people can't say
and they
they would
they're just not in a position in their
lives to say it you can i can because i
don't owe anyone anything
i'm a free person and um
i can say what i see and what i think
and this is this is a position of
privilege there's no doubt about that
um but i know that most people can't say
it and there's a reason which is that
they will be called a racist now i might
be called a racist by some people i'm
certainly not a racist but i i will
inevitably be called a racist by some
people because i'm saying something that
is true and unpopular
and the only or the best tool
that uh my opponents have is to accuse
people of racism
and
for me that's
it's ugly it's unpleasant i i dislike it
i just like it partly in large pockets
it's untrue uh it's reputationally
damaging
as it would be if people called me a
misogynist or a homophobe or anything
else
um
but i i think i can survive it i hope i
can survive a touch board
uh but most people can't
because most people
going about their lives getting on with
their jobs if they would if they would
have that allegation made against them
it could very easily be over so if
you're just working in a company and
you're told that you're going to do
racial bias training
and you're told that you should read um
robyn d'angelo's work about and think
about your white privilege which john
mcwhorter uh called the second worst
book he's ever read read
yes
the first worst book was i wanted to say
it's like a
some
fan fiction book about something like
something completely catastrophic right
okay but he said it was the second worst
book but would be useful to um fix the
leg of a
wobbly car yeah yeah i i think it is up
there as among the the worst tomes i've
ever had to delve through i mean every
page
no the the the the um autobiography of
rudolph huss the camp commandant of
auschwitz was also deeply um every page
because he among as well as being a war
criminal he couldn't write and every
page of his memoirs absolutely apart
from being disgusting and brutal
and gleeful it was it was all alleged it
was also just like turgidly badly
written i remember when i read that i
thought that's a terrible that's a
terrible book and
robin deangelo's book is is probably for
me the second one impressive after that
um
but yes um the point is is if you're in
a
place in your life where you're told to
do these things you're told to talk
about white privilege and
and contemplate that and you said i'm
not doing that
not doing that don't have privilege
uh you're very likely to be in serious
trouble and there's lots of people who
have been there's a there was a partner
at the firm kpmg who lost his job just
because he said that he thought implicit
bias training was crab
he lost his job he was a partner
a big firm you know
so let alone if you're one of the poor
underlings who has to be put through
this rubbish
um
so
so yeah and anyhow it's time this is
stopped is my view
and um not enough people are willing to
say that i am but it is time to stop i'm
not willing to allow people to keep
talking about white people as being
innately privileged
uh they don't know a damn thing about
most people
you cannot work out somebody's life
their experiences their privileges or
their
sufferings
because of their skin color
it's a gross generalization it would be
against black people it is against white
people
and i think also we have to call time on
this ridiculous notion that there are
racial groupings who have something to
apologize for for historic reasons
uh you and i are both
both brought born and brought up in the
united kingdom
uh we are told now that we have some
hereditary um
responsibility for slavery and i mean
americans only have responsibility for
slavery you and i have responsibility
not only for slavery but colonialism
well
chris neither you nor i did anything in
the slave era either you nor i did
anything in the colonial era long before
our time the british navy police the
high seas two centuries before we were
born uh in order to
stop the slave trade not just in britain
but across the world
uh the colonies fell apart decades
before we were born so
no hereditary guilt from me
and i have none from you i have none
from anybody there's no such thing it's
a vile idea
it's a vile idea that cert
it would be permissible in a way as an
idea if you agree that everybody bore
some responsibility for things that
their societies had done in the past
that were bad do they not
but they don't it's one directional it's
only a western thing and i explained the
book i mean like other societies do not
do this and they just don't do this uh
like china is not currently um trying to
work out what it did historically wrong
in this slave era china um
did as much slaving as anyone still is
uh actually um um we have um effective
we have 40 million slaves in the world
today
which is more than there were in the
19th century
more slaves alive today than there were
in the 19th century during the slave
trade 40 million you said alive today
yeah
i've met slaves i've met former slaves
in africa and elsewhere people were born
as slaves and he's escaped
uh this is not an abstract point i'm
making i think that us um beating
ourselves up over over a trade which our
own country got rid of two centuries ago
and if anyone should be proud got rid of
and um
and so on
there is
a significant likelihood we are not
dealing with for instance slavery today
because we're so obsessed with going
over again an issue that was closed two
centuries ago
and
you know it brings to mind a phrase of
nietzsche's in the genealogy of morals
he's a people who there's a type of
person who
who who tears that wounds long clothes
and then shrieks about the pain they
feel
um we're dealing with a lot of those
people at the moment they do not
themselves feel pain from the slave
trade they not feel pain from
colonialism they have decided to rip at
a long closed wound and then cry in
order to win something whether it's pity
or money or reparations or something
everybody would have their own view on
it but um i i refuse to go along with
this idea that as i say
if everybody decided to take upon
themselves exactly the amount of
as i say it's a horrible idea hereditary
sin but exactly the proportion of
hereditary sin that their own society
was accorded then that would be one
thing it's quite another thing when only
one group of people and that white
westerners are expected to be
responsible for everything that anyone
who looked even remotely like them in
the past did
and everybody else is not i mean the
obvious example to give is
is a point of voltaire made in in the um
18th century it says um said somewhere
the only thing
by the way voltaire now is one of the
many figures who's been torn down
literally in paris his statue has been
now removed by the authorities in paris
on the great rationalist thinkers of
french society his
statue was attacked so many times by
people throwing red painted it that it's
now removed and you can't find it
embarrassed nobody knows quite where
voltaire is today
um but now part of the allegation is him
that he profited through shares in some
slave companies they forgot to forget by
the way that voltaire also
wrote in candide one of the great great
um
attacks on slavery but voltaire says in
his own day he says well the only thing
the only thing worse than what the
europeans have done
uh to the africans
is what africans have done to their
fellow africans is what africans have
done to their brothers and sisters
we know uh from
the the few memoirs we had have
of uh people who were slaves in this
period people like ecuano
or
most amazing man who was
end up so british and uh was baptized in
westminster became a free man uh had
most extraordinary life a man was well
worth reading we know from him that
friends and many many others of course
that uh he he was he was stolen by his
neighbors
in africa
uh in the 1700s they um a neighboring
village they came and they snatched them
at night that's what they were people
snatches
and these africans stole their neighbors
and um and sold them
and um now um what is the moral
responsibility of the descendants of the
people stealers
um
if
white westerners have take some guilt
then i would like guilt uh from africans
as well
uh what do you do about
african-americans who are descended both
from slavers and slaves
um what's their
guilt hereditary wise they cash out at
zero they would they would come out at
yes exactly
the balance sheet you end up you know
there um uh if you uh
uh one when i was researching the
slavery
section of this book
um i got into the very interesting story
of the other slave or the other major
slave trade of the of the time whilst
the transatlantic slave trade was going
on which was the arab slave trade and
the arabs had a huge safe trade that
went on for much longer than the western
one the transatlantic one it's thought
that maybe 10 11 uh 10 or 11 million
people were transported across the
atlantic during the height of during the
whole of the period of this slave trade
it was an appalling thing it was
it was a
unbelievably horrible uh trade which
people at the time most people at the
time didn't think was wrong because
people in the past thought differently
from us and almost well all
civilizations sadly at that point they'd
all
engaged in slavery everyone did slave
labor how were the pyramids built you
know the
the pharaohs didn't do it themselves
they didn't pay a fair day's
labor wages to the people who who hauled
the stones for miles uh the acropolis in
athens was not
built by stones dragged up there by
arsenal willing
employees yeah i went to a uh i went to
a church in florence that was nearly
2000 years old and it overlooks downtown
florence and the tour guide was
explaining to us i'm like thinking
the this building's nearly 2 000 and
it's been built up over time but still
the foundations are 2000 years old and a
lot of the the frontage of it is
over a thousand years old and i said
well how is it that people from so long
ago were able to make a building which
has stood the test of time he said well
you don't have the cost of labor
yes yes that's right that's right well
i'll come on to them in a second because
it's a very that's a very
important
point um but just to finish that thought
on the the the arab slave trade it was
was about um 50 more people in total
uh during the same period so if 10 to 11
million or so were taken across the
atlantic in the transatlantic slave
trade it's thought maybe as many as 18
million
from where to were taken from africa to
what we now call the middle east uh arab
countries by who arabia
by the arabs
the arabs traded as the europeans did in
slaves from africa
now you may wonder
why
therefore are there not um
more black people in the middle east and
there's an answer which was this was
actually a genocide
they um
the arabs
deliberately
castrated every single male
so any any african male they took uh to
the arab countries was castrated in
order there would be no more black
people
um
now does that have a legacy to date be
sure it does if you go to
uh qatar
various of the gulf states you'll find
um that they basically have a slave
labor class today the filipinos and
others who are brought in and have
effectively slave conditions i've seen
it myself dubai is the same dubai
uh nobody like fifa cares about this
but this is the case today uh in um in
saudi arabia and other arab countries
the word for
a black person abid
plural abid is slave
they still call black people slaves
my friend diane uh who's
born in somalia spent a bit of time in
uh in saudi arabia she was growing up
and they were black because they were in
somalia and there was any blacker than
the people in saudi arabia and they were
always called abid
slaves so
so my my point is not in any way to
at all diminish what the european slave
trade was what the transatlantic slave
trade was but it is very very strange to
live in an era where it is presumed that
only
the west was engaged in such a thing and
only we for the rest of time must repay
a debt which it appears can never be
paid
down um
and that brings me to what you were just
saying about uh what was going on in uh
countries foreign at the time i mean
didn't you say that the life expectancy
of a worker in lancashire yeah england
was exactly half of that of a slave yeah
working at the time the average the
average man in the north of england
working in a male
you know a mine
they died in their late 30s
so
i'm sorry
but
yes this is different from being a slave
but it's not so wildly different that we
are able to talk about those people in
the north of england as
benefiting from privilege
these were not privileged people
these were not privileged people
these these people did not have very
many life choices of themselves and
here's one of the main points to make
about all this is the past was pretty
much hell for pretty much everyone
i mean
even kings
died and princes died of diseases which
you'd now cure by a
shot of penicillin
um
but the poor
who was almost everyone
they were not privileged people
and the idea that we have to recast all
the ancestors of people who happen to be
white
as oppressors
and the ancestors of everyone who
happens to be black solely as oppressed
is an incredibly simplistic game and
it's unfair
and that's one of the main problems
about it is it's just deeply unfair
and uh when you find an unfair game like
that you should ask yourself
why are we allowing this game to be
played like this by people who literally
declare themselves sheriff well what's
the goal of revising history why do it
well
we revise history all the time and we
should i'm not trying to stop anyone
carrying out historical investigations
far from it i say in the book
i i'm not against historical revisionism
i think the revisionists need to be
revised in turn because i think they've
had too
fast and fuller run
i'm not i'm not against understanding
any of this in the round
what i'm against is trying to understand
it
through a very narrow ideological lens
and here's the thing um i mean if we'd
have been born like 50 years earlier
than we were
we would almost certainly have had an
education in the uk where there would
have been a map on the school room wall
of uh
the uh the globe
and the great
pink of the british empire
and we'd have been brought out to say
good god what a great amount of the
earth that we own isn't that terrific
and uh we're a tiny country below now
we've got all of that that's just grand
and the teacher would have told us about
these great heroic people who went out
and made this possible
now
that was not history in the round
that was a very
narrow
ideological
view
of empire
well
unfortunately it's also a narrow and
highly ideological view of empire to do
what we're currently doing
which is to say you must only look at
empire by for instance equating it with
the worst actions of the third reich you
know the
you can only compare it with narcissism
you can't say
well
it's a complex thing
some benefits for some countries
a lot of
negatives for a lot of countries
um
and the only people who tried to add any
any context and make any of the
necessary corrections to the overreach
have been just
destroyed
uh people like professor nigel bigger
from oxford university in the wake of
the cecil rhodes affair at oxford when
there was an attempt to pull down this
statue of
an undoubted colonialist cecil rhodes
who also endowed his former colleague
college at oxford oriole as an attempt
to pull down his statue and this
professor at oxford regis professor at
oxford in ethics nigel biger a very fine
man um objects this and says why don't
we since we're a university we shouldn't
allow these lies to be told about
accessible roads which is what people
were doing they were making up quotes of
things you said when what he said was
quite bad enough but they invented
quotes and said he'd use the n-word in
contexts he had and all this sort of
thing
and nigel bigger this professor said why
don't we try to set up a course at
oxford where we study the ethics of
empire in the round
you know try to work out a moral
calculus as it were of what
what it meant now that would be a really
good and reasonable project he wasn't
allowed to do it
fellow academics by the hundreds
denounced him
um
how can you even think of trying to put
this into context they all said
um and one of the main arguments they
used repeatedly was
you you you can't excuse empire because
to excuse empire would be a beat excuse
for instance the amritsar massacre
uh which was the time uh when british
troops opened fire on an unarmed crowd
of protesters in amritsar
in india not to be confused with the
time when andira gandhi ordered a
massacre of far more indians on the same
spot those they do things and not to be
confused at all
but the time when uh the british opened
fire and winston churchill in the house
of commons denounces it as a as as
um
one of the greatest crimes of the era he
says it's a great stain on the british
empire that such a thing should have
happened and it was
and uh
the um uh colonel kendall dyer who
ordered
the soldiers to open fire on this
unarmed crowd
um he uh was put into retirement
immediately
um you might say worse should have
happened to him but that's what happened
and there was an incredible outcry now
um some hundreds of people were killed
in amritsar
but again is it
is it impossible to work out
what the benefits were for certain
countries of
um
british presence
um is it wrong to think that hong kong
benefited from british presence or
singapore or
societies which have flourished or did
flourish in the case of hong kong until
quite recently is it wrong to try to
work out why the places succeeded
succeeded and why the places that failed
failed and what went right and what went
wrong and
whether you could find a ledger that
seems to me to be a very good reasonable
enterprise
why is it that
winston churchill has been seen as a
racist but karl marx has been seen as a
hero yeah i'm so glad that's one of my
favorite bug bears
um
uh
yeah
well
here's my short answer
uh there is an attempt to take down all
of our heroes
all of our heroes
winston churchill for the british is our
hero our national hero only 20 years ago
when we were allowed an opportunity to
vote on who the greatest briton was bbc
had this
bbc documentary
10 people were when they ended up being
shortlisted i think and people presented
a program on each and the um
and the the person who won hands down is
the greatest britain of all time was
winston churchill of course
um
now in 2022 uh even the bbc whenever it
runs a piece by winston churchill has to
run like
the case for the for the um prosecution
like ten
terrible things winston churchill did
um they've just
been decided to recast him in a
different light and again a very unfair
light he's accused of a lot of things he
didn't do
such as
gassing iraqis in fact he and this is a
gnome chomsky like he actually used not
to get too much into the weeds but
churchill ordered the use of what we
would now call tears
not mustard gas and chomsky and others
have pretended that he used mustard gas
on the iraqis that lie has gone round
repeatedly there are other other all
sorts of other accusations against
churchill but basically it's because
um the british
love and admire winston churchill still
not everybody there are some critics
but by and large he is our biggest
national hero
and um you know when the film finest
hour came out
you know there were lots of stories of
um
people
in cinemas at the end getting to their
feets and feet and doing standing
ovations
um
and
i mean i don't know if you feel this but
i feel very strongly that uh
churchill is it's it's not just about
him
um in britain there's a view that
and i think it's correct that
the world would certainly have
um
allowed nazism to flood across europe
and possibly to britain
if churchill hadn't been in place at
that time
who was it that said this is the one
time i've seen the hand of god at work
in the real world yeah yeah lord
halesham said it's one time i've seen
the hand of god
um operate in politics it felt like it
just the mo that
that that churchill being put into place
at that moment was just a godsend and it
was and the other thing is of course he
he
for all of our families in britain i
mean he was the rallying figure along
with the king and the queen
um
who showed the british people
the resilience necessary to sacrifice
their sons
a second time within a few decades
because he done one fought on six
continents or something or five
continents he'd put himself forward for
world war one volunteered to fight in
world war one
fantastic hats
smokes
drank a lot um
but he represented and represents still
for a lot of us in britain this
a sense of what our spirit is which is
um a difficult belligerent unbowed
um
uh dogged
um
not self-pitying
um
and much more
and
so why have they come for churchill
i explained it the ways in which they've
come for him but my answer as to why is
because they know that it will
demoralize us who's they
the people who hate the west in general
who hate britain who hate america
if you take down they hate people like
churchill being admired
they can't bear it because they know
that it's something so deep within us
now what is that deep thing for me and i
think for a lot of other british people
it is
the sense
that we're a good country
that we did something good that
france may have given in
that
with the only shots fired being against
french soldiers by french soldiers but
as good as a cross over that
uh you know the dutch
rolled over
a lot of other countries didn't have a
choice and so on and so forth but the
british wouldn't and this is because we
were a good country and we faced up to
bad people when we saw them
that is a very very important
feeling nationally but if you want to
stop the british feeling pride in
themselves you've got to take out
winston churchill
in the same way in america
if you hate america you not only hate
the fact that founding fathers are
revered and they've been my god as i say
in the chapter on history they've really
come for the founding fathers in recent
years
now you might say again there's a
historical revisionism that was needed
uh 60 years ago people in america who
revered jefferson say didn't necessarily
know he was a slave owner
we know today it'd be nice to know
something other than the fact he was a
slave owner
but the point is if you attack the
founding fathers you attack an idea of
america if you take down lincoln
the victor of the civil war
and that's also happening
literally this and i've seen themselves
with statues of lincoln torn down in
america
if you tear down lincoln
you go in a similar way to attack the
foundation of america because if you
don't have lincoln you basically don't
have america and again not just because
he was a good man
who won the civil war
and and and
did this extraordinary thing
not just because of that but also
because his whole story was a story of
coming from nothing
and becoming president
i mean he grew up in
absolute poverty lincoln probably had
one year of formal education everything
else he was self-taught
he taught himself to read books
he was a remarkable man
who imbued a spirit of america which
many americans still feel but if you
take down lincoln
you've taken down the idea of america
now sorry one other point the quick
point on that why didn't they do it to
marx
ah
well
the same remorseless battle is the same
remorseless attack is made
on every historical figure in the west
on every philosopher of the west every
cultural hero of the west
and it's always done the same way they
lived in a time of slavery and did
something to endorse it or didn't work
against it enough they lived in a time
of colonialism and didn't attack it
enough or benefited from it in some way
they were racist by modern standards
this is done against everybody everybody
in american history and in british
history in western history except for
karl marx
what a coincidence is this um
i i took great delight searching the
book finding out the
many many racist things that karl marx
said
in his private letters his private
letters to engels he constantly uses the
n word often
linked to jew profoundly anti-semitic of
course
extraordinarily bad views on slavery on
colonialism everything else
he said much more racist things than any
of the people that we've discussed
discussed so far
including churchill
and yet weirdly he doesn't get the same
treatment
so if you take out every thinker
other than karl marx
why would that be
other than that you're not really just
you're not really carrying out a fair
critique
you're carrying out a deliberately
unfair critique in order to advance an
existing cause
the existing cause in this case is
anything but westernism and marxism is
one of the answers
and i'm afraid that anti-westernism has
always been
whipped along by marxism ever since
the benighted birth of karl marx
um
he
uh
even in the post-colonial era as i say
in the books but one of the great
ironies of the post-colonial era
is that
anti-colonialists like fanner who i
write about all said we've got to get
rid of western rule in africa
now you could say well
at this point we must return africa to a
pre-colonial time a kind of native
tradition
which would have included all sorts of
traditions which would also not look
very nice in the light of modern thought
um
the obar of benin was not a liberal
democrat and uh much more anyway but the
point you you that they didn't say that
they people like fanon said we must get
the europeans out of uh africa and stop
the european colonialism and capitalism
in order that we can institute western
marxism
well
this is an oddity at the very least but
as i say i think it's one of these
things the fact that people don't apply
this standard to certain people and do
to others is a demonstration that we
that they are engaging in a bad faith
argument
the thing that i keep coming back to is
the why right what the end goal
is of this i don't deny that you know i
was kind of shocked when we saw statues
of
people that i thought probably shouldn't
have been torn down like winston
churchill seemed like a bit of a stupid
idea to tear down what was it abraham
lincoln setting free a slave that got
down at one point i was like well that
kind of seems like
symbolically kind of beautiful rather
than uh racists or imperial or whatever
to me um
so i i don't disagree that the things
that you're bringing up seem to have
happened what i'm s
the leap that i'm struggling to make is
like what's the agenda why is this i
it's
dissolving the west's love for itself
the attachment of whiteness with
westernness because westernness had
some baggage that came along from the
past and then by attaching the two you
make the the personal
part of the ideological part of the
historical part of the impression
why like what's the end goal are you
suggesting that this is a slow march of
marxism is that who's pushing this i
like one of the people pushing it the
first thing to say
there is a totally as i try to stress
there is a totally
reasonable
genesis to it which is there are things
from our past we have not looked at
enough
and perhaps we ought to understand more
fully in the round
there is also a totally uh legitimate
understandable sense of you know
were we always the good guys that's a
pretty good question to ask
um
and uh and and
you know by the way only the west
engages in this sort of self-criticism
but fine it doesn't need to be something
everyone does so that that's one thing
it's a perfectly reasonable attempt to
get ourselves in the round
um
uh
my belief is is that
there is
there are several other things going on
and just to limit them to a couple
one is
internationally
this is also pushed on us
uh just the day before speaking i i saw
that the china daily news which is one
of the communist party of china's
propaganda organs
put out on twitter
a cartoon of uncle sam behind the oval
office desk
um surrounded by bodies and sort of you
know uncle sam
america has always you know been racist
and so on and said you know
george floyd and separation of families
at the border
he's going along like they're saying
i mean
does anyone really think the communist
party china minds about separating
families
does it mind that with the uyghurs
does it mind the fact is carrying out
currently
or the worst human rights abuse
currently occurring anywhere on the
globe and that's saying something
um do you honestly think the chinese
care about the death of george floyd
we don't know the names
of the people killed in china
of course they don't care about it but
they push it on us because they know
that we're that a certain number of us
are
receptive to that
the same thing with russia
russia and others have for years
encouraged this sense of
self-loathing in the west because they
have a different sense of themselves
uh so
our foes and our competitors
take advantage of this self-criticism
because it is not something that they
share
and they
and then we have this thing of total
self-abnegation
what's that mean self-obligation is
the desire to rid yourself basically of
everything that you have
for a culture to
get rid of everything because it's all
bad
and that's what i try to write about in
the culture chapter is to show that you
know we're even doing this throughout
our culture
i mean
phrases like dead white men
suddenly took
got currency in recent years
dead white men
and people could talk about
people in these terms i mean it's it's
again
dead black men oh that was just dead
black men who would say that
who'd say that
oh that's just the legacy of dead white
men
um
this this became
um
a
process of self-scourging in recent
years
and um
i'm afraid that a lot of it is done by
bad actors bad faith actors and a lot of
it is done by ignoramuses i'm afraid um
one of the easiest
ways to
make yourself look clever in the modern
era is just to be anti-western to blame
us for everything go it was it reflexive
anti-westernism yes i mean
but
let's put it the other way around i mean
that is a sort of easy way to to put
that let's put it the harder way
um how easy is it today for anyone in in
the modern west to stand up in a public
forum on television say and list the
accomplishments of the west
who would do it
well it's not like we don't have
accomplishments we could talk about
simply in the political arena we could
just mention
the evolution of
representative democracy
the concept of one man one vote one
woman one vote a lot of the world's got
nowhere near that
concept of the peaceful transfer of
power
the maintaining of political order
the rule of law
okay this is a very small number of
things but everything i've just listed
is pretty big
most of africa
historically the middle east
historically the far east historically
does not have
the
the peaceful transfer of power
it's one group
oppressing another group and taking
their stuff
i think russia hasn't had a
a peaceful transfer of power through the
actual uh appropriate
uh mechanism
maybe ever
yes i mean you you could maybe say that
well no you're
well it depends how you interpreted the
communist party in the
cold war era transferring power from
leader to leader which was sort of
peaceful on their terms
um
but under a system which people had no
say in i mean you know
not at all you had this quote i think
that relates to what you were just
mentioning there uh when you are
speaking into a great vacuum of
ignorance people with malign intent can
run an awfully long way awfully fast
yeah
yeah
it's absolutely true they um
uh if if you are brought up to and i was
slightly in this when i was a student
um
you don't know the world you don't know
very much about the rest of the world
you've not been to much of the rest of
the world yet
and when asked anything about it you've
only got this prism of where you come
from and
and if you're taught well it's us that's
responsible for everything then it's
quite easy to just always look at
everything through that lens
but it's not a correct lens i mean it's
it's a lens it's not it's not a
fair one
one of you like critique in the book
edward syed who wrote the book
orientalism which always all students
still read unfortunately
accuses western scholars and approaching
the middle east and looking at it
through orientalist eyes of looking at
it with european eyes and
everyone since
syed wrote this seems to think this is a
brilliant insight it's not a brilliant
insight at all i mean what eyes were
they meant to look at the middle east
through chinese eyes
japanese eyes of course they looked it
through the eyes of the place they came
from and interpreted it as such just in
the same way as an arab traveling to
europe in the 17th century would have
looked at europe through arab eyes
um there's nothing particularly
surprising or racist about that
um but in our era we have we have been i
think taught that that a that a
um a civilized a um
a person who wanted to sound clever a
person who wanted to be thought well of
uh and much more would
would laugh this would
would would would scorn what i just said
about for instance
just some of the political gifts that
the west has
has handed down
um george orwell you remember from that
famous essay line the unicorn says that
the average um
english sort of english or english
intellectual i think he's it was a
particular example you would
rather die than stand up to the national
anthem you know that's different in
america by the way but there was always
something in it and now and that that
observation of all wells has often been
used to sort of show we have a more
subtle form of patriotism a more subtle
form of national feeling and so on and
so forth
but there is a form of that that can be
very very easily adapted into shame only
shame only there is a version of it
which can be pride only and that's
ridiculous as well in a way just just to
be
i mean i'm not
as you well know i'm not a top-thumping
flag-waving nationalist of any kind
um i
i love my country
and i think it's been a broader force of
good in the world certainly more of a
force of good than it has for ill i
think the same thing of america um
and um
i'm
much
more pleased that britain and america
had global dominance in the 20th century
than say that china or russia had
um
and you know i i think that i think that
for some reason generationally there's
just been this rebellion against what's
perceived to be sort of jingoistic and
and simply what does that mean what's
that being jingoistic it was to be sort
of nationalist and um
um you know
only us you know the rest you know you
don't you don't see abroad abroad is
awful you know um
and um there has been a sort of
rebellion against that
that that perceived trend and and
there's an understandable one i i would
rebel against that if i saw it all the
time all over the place you know
um
uh but we don't see it all the time all
over the place quite the opposite all of
our cultural institutions are busy
giving up our heritage as far as i can
see it as i lay out in the book
um all of our cultural custodians seem
to me to be doing everything but looking
after the culture which they're meant to
be looking after well the
fortunate thing for black people is that
you have blm and the virtuous use of
donations
that can keep everything on track you
don't need to worry
daddy's in the hot seat absolutely how
many mansions does that girl who started
that woman who started to have now she's
left now right the first lady that did
it last one who's got the five mansions
silent oh very sort of quietly
slipped away i saw
after the news story about the six
million dollar mansion came out do you
see that there was an internal memo
leaked oh about this go on so an
internal memo got circulated uh in an
effort to see how they could downplay
the fact that the six million dollar
mansion
was there um they got caught lying about
this is uh
they got caught lying about its purpose
apparently so it was i think they called
it they called it like the center oh i
see or the high community center
something like that yeah six million
dollar mansion um and then they had
everybody sign ndas and then they sent
uh private investigators after the
journalists that were looking into it
but when you have a lot of donations
you're allowed to and one of the things
that was interesting this was reported
or one of the um
instigators for why this began becoming
investigated was because of some of the
local communities that were expecting
support from blm
had found that they weren't getting
support so you had people who were
struggling to make rent who were living
in these sort of impoverished
communities and stuff like that
and meanwhile yeah the original
director ceo somebody uh has slipped out
but still in her wake there is a uh an
aftershock of a six million dollar
mansion she has still held on to five or
so properties well you need to
yeah i mean you've got to go from one
swimming pool to another it's easy to
get bored with one swimming pool uh this
is a this is a hustle and i mean if if
if if if no one did you call it black
lives racket black lives racket that's
right i'm one of my roles i write a
weekly column for the new york post and
um
we we ran a great front page on this
benighted um news emerged
i think posts were on the i think they
tried to come for the post actually on
exposing this
um
yeah i think these people are um i mean
you ask about motives and things and
this is the easiest one of course
uh on another mansion and another
mention uh um black lives mansions was
fun
we ran um
only the post
and uh
the
um yeah the the the
the impetus for these people is so
obvious so damn clear um and it's so
it's it's just it's such a it's such a
shame for so many reasons
you know they
like a lot of sort of charity like
things they have to present a situation
as being worse
than it is in order to maximize profits
and all the gay rights groups do that
now i mean i wish they'd all just shut
up and shut down and go home
uh but they don't they all they all
they've all got pensions and dress you
know
in invested interests these are all
vested interests and they they have to
all these groups and blms the classic
stuff we have to make the situation
appear worse than it is they have to
exaggerate the extent of racism in
america for instance in order to
maximize donations they then have to
mislead a load of perfectly sometimes
perfectly decent people not always into
handing over money they get corporations
to hand over effectively ransom money i
mean it's a sort of protection racket
you know awfully nice business you've
got the shame if anyone accused you of
racism
um
and uh and then you've got the the the
people who
um who were expecting to benefit and and
and don't benefit because the whole
thing was a hustle well
you know in america
we have a very clear um
sense of i say weeks we're sitting here
but um
of a certain type of
pasta hackster you know
i remember this in the post the other
week you know they're the sort of
tammy faye baker sort of figures who who
you know um
uh
they still go on a bit actually there's
one in texas still who so you know they
like take out huge tv commercials and
they say you know you gotta hand over
your
your money because i just gotta have a
helicopter
i was in the car i was in the car
yesterday in an uber and i i've taken
since i've been here i usually listen to
classic fm uh to wake up on a morning
what i've found is that when i first
wake up if i listen to music i can't get
the song out of my head and sometimes
with classic fm this can be really
awkward because a lot of the music is
done to the same pace that i walk at and
that means as i'm walking down the
street i'm i'm creating the drum beat to
the song that i'm trying to get out of
my own head so out here i've taken to
listening to uh
um keeping him close by
which is a local houston christian radio
station anyway got in the car yesterday
uber driver had a different
station on and they were doing a
60-second countdown
donation
drive
uh and saying you know
if if you feel moved
to submit this money then you can
you know it's it's going to help it is
there for a good reason i don't know and
then it was if they got
if this particular station that must be
part of a bigger network got more money
than the other stations that were
in different areas in the country on the
same network
maybe the presenters wanted a trip to
some i don't know but it just felt so
icky to me and that's you know that
that's being broadcast on the radio this
isn't you know the pastor huckster doing
it to a small town and that that was
that sort of commercializing of of
donations you know using a bunch of
psychological tricks a one-time offer a
countdown timer yeah this is click
funnels from 2006
you know with a oh and here's an upsell
for just another five dollars you can
get our free dvd course that you can
whatever whatever it's it's a bit of a
bit of a tangent i've got to say there's
no greater joy than for a british person
to just sit down and watch adverts on
american television uh i once some years
guys in
los angeles and i was watching a
television channel hopping and there was
a
an advert from a local funeral home
a 999.99
[Music]
creation funeral all in
uh offer was only available for another
month
what can you do with that i mean granny
look
there's this amazing offer and i know
you're not well
this office is only on for another month
there is a long set of stairs if you
would if you were going to live another
five weeks you wouldn't be able to take
advantage of this magnificent offer
so
you know anyhow but the point is is that
yes we all know that type of huxster and
and and you know tin rattling maniac who
who who who comes from a sort of certain
type of truth because they have a better
instagram page now right blm is is one
of those
i'm sad that it's taken this amount of
time
to people to wake up to it i'm sorry
that they did become that you know they
could have been a civil rights
campaigning organization
campaigning for remaining
legitimate complaints of black americans
but they didn't do that they just became
another racquet even supporters of them
now or supporters of the movement have
started to distance themselves by using
two different terms right people talk
about black lives matter
to refer to the movement and they talk
about blm to refer to the organization
uh and as soon as you as soon as i
started to see that it's like yeah that
won't work that's a sign of um internal
uh dispute yeah
are you concerned
about
white supremacists using the pro-white
narrative that you've got with this to
further some pretty nasty agendas that
they might have
i don't have a pro-white narrative in
the book
by any means they're not pro-white
anymore than i'm pro-black or anything
i'm
i'm just i'm for
people not being told
that they're inherently bad because of
racial characteristics we've drawn a
line between
pro-western
and western being associated with
whiteness though so there is you know
we're only a couple of steps away from
well because most people in in
historically in the west have been white
um so yes and it's hard to attack the
west without attacking white people or
to attack white people without attacking
the west but i'm not making a pro-white
argument because i mean it's it's like
any more than any point in making a
pro-black argument okay but let's say
it's a pro-west argument
and then that's then going to be perhaps
co-opted by some
slightly nasty groups well
the the first thing is is that as a
first thing as a writer you have
responsibility for the words you write
um
and i've been a writer for
22 years now in my adult life
uh you have responsibility for the words
you write
um other people have responsibility for
their actions and their words
uh i find the attempt sometimes to
make writers
responsible for their readers to be
essentially unfair
um
i think you write as carefully as you
can i certainly do
um
and
will
can i guarantee that nobody with
unpleasant views will read the book no i
can't
um my very large readership
which i'm very fortunate to have
i can't promise that
that you know everybody is going to be
exactly of my mindset
or have exactly my
tolerant views i
uh i would hope they do
um but i find this sort of an attempt
i'm not saying you're doing it but the
attempt by a lot of people sort of lie
the difference between author and reader
to be
sort of unfair i mean obviously jordan
gets quite a lot of that the sort of uh
you know you're read by young in-cell
sort of thing it says it's not it's not
really fair as well as not provable and
not the case
um
uh and in any case i mean as far as i
can tell
what actual racists and white
supremacists still exist and there's a
little little bit more of it in america
than there is in the uk i think a little
bit more but there's a tiny tiny uh
um
way out there fringe figures
um
wouldn't and don't like me anyway
because i won't speak in their terms or
agree with what they think what would be
the differences
all sorts of things i mean for instance
i i don't tell people that being white
is better than being black
because i don't think it is
i think that i think these things are
morally neutral states
i think
the very idea of saying something that
somebody that they should feel pride in
their skin color
is as absurd as all of the other claims
you should feel pride about innate
characteristics i mean
look let's take
being a man like if somebody said
actually somebody did say this to me a
weird question but i said chris are you
proud of being a man
i'm like
i
i'm not proud of being a man
i'm not
unproud of i'm not ashamed of being a
man
certainly not ashamed of being a man
but i'm not proud of it because i didn't
do anything
i'm not ashamed of being white
and i'm not proud of being white because
i didn't do anything
that's one of the reasons why i've
always hated the gay pride thing so if
you believe in pride you believe in
shame
why would you be proud of being gay just
just don't feel shame about being gay
it's fine just get out of your bloody
life and shut up but the the the the the
what i'm trying to get to is that
a white supremacist would say
and does say i have great pride in being
white and it makes me better than these
other people well i don't believe that i
don't feel i have any pride in being
white per se
and i don't think that being white makes
me better than anyone else but but
here's the deal in that
i i i require no persuading that this is
my
belief because it's been my belief
throughout my life i was born and
brought up in very multicultural london
in the 1980s and
you know it's not like
like i learned
you know to be
to have my views i just it's been
what i've thought throughout my life
um if you uh if you said um
if if but but so the point i'm trying to
come to is that
i don't think i'm better than anyone
else because of my skin color or my
sex or anything
but i also don't think anyone else is
better than me because of theirs
i don't think
i'm better than a black person because i
happen to be white
and i also don't think they're better
than me because they happen to be black
but if some but
if somebody
distorts that equation
and a white supremacist will distort
that that equation by saying
no of course the white person is better
than the black person i think that's
racist and horrible
and abhorrent
but i also think it's racist and
horrible and abhorrent if a black person
thinks that they are better than a white
person by dint of being black now the
first of those two things is almost
entirely societally
condemned the second of those it's not
clear that it is
and i think that many of us can feel
that in public spaces where certain
people
and everyone is always on the cusp of it
a white person in a debate with a black
person is always vulnerable to the
possibility that they will be accused of
racism at some point and if they are
that is disastrous
but that is because the black person on
the stage effectively still holds this
at the moment a certain unequal power in
that regard
it sometimes takes people a while to
work out but that in the current era we
are in that is the dynamic
in the same way that a man and a woman
debating on stage it just requires a
woman to say to the man oh thank you for
mansplaining that
now the perception we still pretend is
that the man is in a position of
dominance on the stage that isn't really
the case in our era nor is it the case
that a white person on stage has
dominance over a black personality
certainly not and just to reiterate i
don't want them to have
i want people to be able to regard each
other as equals
not better nor worse because of
characteristics over which we have no
say
aside from the problems on the left
which we've been through do you worry
about the
trends towards sort of populists or the
endorsements of conspiracy theories in
some right-wing parties at the moment
which ones well i mean the kovid
conspiracy theories we've seen that were
pushed i mean marjorie taylor green was
in an interesting position such an idiot
um
and
is it bolsonaro i think as well seems to
be somebody that's yeah
i don't i don't follow very much about
brazilian politics but yeah he seems to
be a nasty piece of work um are you
concerned about that at the moment you
know we've seen sort of trumpist wing
and claims of the leaders like bolsonaro
uh
i never bought this idea that there was
a sort of populist surge
in recent years because i don't like the
term populist and without getting into
definitions
um
[Music]
by the actual definitions of populism
the most prominent successful populist
in the world is emmanuel macron
um but uh
in the current era the idea has been
that populism is only something of the
right which is it's not really not not
correct it's also centrist phenomenon
and a leftist phenomenon
so there's a certain interpretation of
politics in recent years which i don't
go along with
a lot of what is called populist is just
popular
voted on by the people
and deemed by a certain type of person
as being the wrong decision to have come
to
am i concerned with certain things on
the left obviously and i spent a certain
amount of my life critiquing that
am i concerned with some things that are
going on the right on the right for sure
not like sure
um i think several things have happened
in recent uh actually in recent months
as well as recent years
uh
uh i'm concerned about the complete the
particular america the complete
breakdown and trust in any institutions
which is
both legitimate and terrifying
uh
i don't i don't know if non-americans
watching will understand the extent
which this is the case but
in america conserv
you know
mainstream conservatives now
for very understandable reasons
do not trust any of the intelligence
agencies of their own country cia nsa
fbi
uh they believe that elections are
rigged
uh or at least unreliable
the results are unreliable
that
um uh the courts are corrupt
therefore
um
and much more the factory the state is
corrupted totally corrupted here's a
problem i mean they're not onto nothing
uh then you've got the additional layers
of the ability of big tech to for
instance silence even the new york post
america's oldest newspaper we talked
about earlier
so the tech companies are corrupted
they've already got the media problem in
america where people don't trust the
media because they see it as being a
sort of
extension of politics and not a
reporting mechanism all of these things
are much more advanced in america than
they are in the uk
uh
and you know you have some
dislike for bbc
but
the bbc is degraded in all sorts of ways
but it's not cnn
it's not seen as partisan not in the
same way exactly people on left and
right
dislike it for different reasons but
it's still got some reporting
credibility
and um
in the uk there are people who dislike
the intelligence services or
you know suspicious of them and so on
and i'm not i don't get impact it makes
even talking about them it sounds
conspiratorial but but i don't think
anyone but not very many people in
britain actively think that they see
that mi5 mi6 and gchq are not on the
side of britain but you would say that
american sections of the significant
sections of the right as the left
have decided that effectively the state
is against the state
that worries you
if you don't have institutions that you
trust it's hard to see what
conservatives are
i mean conservatism is
innately
tied up with trust in institutions
so i worry about that a conspiratorial
thinking is definitely um
i mean just washed up in well in all of
our countries and again the problem is
with some reason i mean
look at the whiplash that occurred in
most people in 2020 when we went from
the most important thing is you stay
locked in your houses and don't see
anyone else
to
the most important thing is to get out
on the street in a tightly packed
environment and protest against racism
i
when the narrative shifts like that and
you're meant to just go along with it
i can see why people get conspiratorial
when they're told that they're not
allowed to say that the
wuhan lab might have been responsible
for the for the league and and you're
told you're a conspiracy theorist if you
believe that and then a year later the
story changes and you're meant to just
go along with it
i can see why people are
or have lost it to a great extent
um
and i'm you know i i'm not the arbiter
of that i don't i don't know i mean
everyone makes their own judgments about
whether other people have lost it or not
but it seems to me that that an awful
lot of people have they've gone down the
line of conspiratorial thinking is that
another way that a lot of conspiracies
work though that there's a maybe a
kernel of truth to act as a gateway drug
yeah and then people
start to tumble
deeper and deeper into this sort of
thinking and it's that's not to say that
there isn't problems similar to this on
the left but
it does seem like the slope may be a
little slipperier i think it's got i
think it's gone
i think it's gone
sharper and slipperier faster on the
right
we know the sort of left
trajectory i have done for a long time
but i mean it's only like three years
since jordan and i sat down in london
and talked about the
uh the way in which the left goes wrong
which is a very interesting conversation
still hasn't been properly addressed but
but but
you know we discussed this in london and
i remember
we said you know we're discussing this
because nobody knows where the left goes
wrong but we all know where the right
goes wrong
but three years later
you know it's not clear to me anymore
that everybody does agree where the
right goes wrong
i mean another example is look at
elements of the right particular america
in relation to russia and ukraine
uh
i mean
you know there is a sort of inevitable
in internet-like meme of you know
always go against whatever is the
prevailing narrative reflexive
heterodoxy right exactly um
everyone seems to be praising this guy
zelensky
i don't want to praise this guy
well everyone's praising him because he
could have done a runner
and lived in the south of france the
rest of his life instead he stayed
risked his life and the life of his
family to stay and fight for his country
and inspire his country to fight like
that's why people admire him it's not
that hard to discern
um
let me give you another one
i mean this is amazing to me now
but there are people on the right again
particularly in america and in europe it
has to be said not in britain so much
which is
a good thing but
certainly in europe and certainly on the
right in america
you have people who now say things only
used to be said on the left uh things
like who are we to say when we went into
iraq and killed x million people now
without getting an argument about the
iraq war we didn't kill x million people
in iraq
uh made what turned out to be a very
inept intervention uh in which local
militias and others and other countries
poured in and then were responsible for
hundreds of thousands of deaths and it's
not a small thing but the we went in and
killed x million people and therefore we
have no right to act used to be a claim
of the sort of chomskyite left and you
now hear it on the right
that that has surprised me that's
happened very fast who are we to condemn
russia when we invaded afghanistan
again i mean i'm very happy to have the
right about that but that used to be a
left-wing thing that did not used to be
a right-wing thing
um and it has become
one
we spent a good bit of time together in
new york which have been some of my
favorite memories from my trip so far
around here
uh you i mean i thought they were all
right you introduced me to uh you
introduced me to manhattan cocktails
which was fantastic
we got into a row with a lady at a
a show a uh harry potter show and we had
some really really interesting
discussions there that i kind of had a
side of you that i hadn't really seen
before and one of the first things i
asked was that you've got five columns a
week that you write at the moment that's
correct i ran an average of four crimes
a week okay yeah uh but plus media spots
plus
writing a book plus the other bits that
you do plus trying to have a life as
well
what is it that drives you
to work that hard
um
gosh that's a difficult question um
i i do work very hard uh
i got to see this first hand yeah reason
i bring it up
yeah
i um
i think i might mention to you i
sometimes have to register that with
myself a few weeks ago i got back maybe
it was when you were in new york i
remember i
got
home one night at about 10 p.m and i
remember having this terrible feeling
but there must be something i've got to
do
and i rise
oh no there isn't
i can relax
and it was 10 p.m at night and that is
not uncommon
at all
um
i sort of say that
one of the great
benefits of the life i've been able to
create has been that i i
work in
in
uh industries trades whatever you want
to call them
where i have to work all of the time
but at about 90 or 80 percent
so
most people work well let's pretend that
most people work nine to five 100
percent
um and then they stop working
and they can do whatever they like the
rest of the time
um uh if you
do what you love
well first of all if you're very busy
and sorry as i i'm i'm in
you just can't do a nine-to-five job i
mean it wouldn't work
and so yeah i work all the time uh
every day i have something i don't think
is it ever a day
when i don't
what drives that uh
a lot of things i suppose one is just
being driven
uh and i don't know if anyone can
explain for themselves why someone why
they're driven i just i just know i
always have been
i always had a um a horror of wasting
time i mean i i i
i'm quite an irritable person it's one
of my
um traits don't smile
you were perfectly pleasant when i said
okay well that's very good
um
i'm slightly irritable at times
um and it's generally because of um a
fear of wasting time
and um
this is very strong in me
uh i can't bear
clothes shopping for instance i can't
bear being in shops actually in general
i get very irritable because i i just
i feel my life going
and i have that in certain films and all
sorts of other things
i i just have a very acute sense of
life's brevity
don't waste it work hard
do whatever it is you're meant to do and
i've got a pretty clear view of what i
need to do
and
so i don't like
not using my time
um
the other thing i suppose i'm motivated
to be the best that i can be
and that includes being the best in my
field um
i could always do less i mean it's one
of those sort of things that your mother
says you know can you not you know can
you do a bit less you know something you
well i could
but then i wouldn't be as successful and
i want to be successful
um
i i want to do well
you know i
um if i've
if i've got a book out like i don't not
promote it
you know because i feel like i've done
the work
um
you prefer them like the columns i write
it's one of the great you know great
pleasures of my life i i get to write
for and speak to millions and millions
of people
in different formats in different
countries in tabloid newspapers and in
broadsheet newspapers
and
enter into and be in
the big debates of my time
and
and i enjoy it
and you know
people generally think i'm quite good at
it and
asked me to do it and
um
and i get a thrill from it and and
you know i said a little while ago to a
friend you know i wish i could have a
couple of days off
and then i said i said i wish i could
just like not have to write anything
for a few weeks and she said no you
don't you'd be like 48 hours and you'd
be like damnit and bored you had a
similar experience with meditation i
think
that's right i'm very very bad at
meditating very very bad meditating uh
yeah i think sam harris wants
to get me to meditate i find that i find
that impossible i'm told that there's a
way to get through that but i couldn't
get through it i i you know all that
thing even when sam said um
it was in room in australia a few years
ago
you know samsung was saying i empty your
mind of all your thoughts and i was just
thinking i'm so irritated
um
[Laughter]
god i always had reading a book
and
i
i
i can't do it and um
anyhow that's my failing i mean sam is
terrific and and he's brilliant at that
and he's helped
millions of people to find a way to do
things like meditation i wish i could do
that but in a way i don't really because
i kind of don't want to turn my mind off
it's always racing it's always looking
for things and you know i read a lot as
you know um books and
things and
and magazines and articles and what but
i read books uh
uh and i read to relax as well which is
very important to him if you do what i
do
um you know you read to extend your
knowledge but you also read things that
just
take you out of
work stuff into something else but even
then
i kind of read with a pencil in my hand
even the relaxing stuff is i have a
sight in the corner of my eye
i have a friend who referred to that
before you have the pencil in your hand
there's low stakes consumption
so he talks about low stakes podcast
listening that if you're constantly
embroiled in the culture wars and you're
always listening the newest whatever yes
at 100 miles an hour it's kind of nice
to just hear about a murder mystery for
for a little while low stakes listening
um but yeah
this is something i've been battling
with so much and we spoke about this
with regards to productivity dysmorphia
as well
this tension between
um the fact that you know that part of
your drive
comes from your ability to pay attention
your ability to constantly be on to be
able to look at the details in a way
that other people don't and that that
can actually lead to almost a fear that
you go okay well hang on if i tune this
down
that is the fuel that's driving a lot of
the achievements that i take so much
pleasure in
and that there's this
difficulty sometimes with seeing the
amount of work that we've done and i i
think maybe we almost don't want to see
the amount of work that we've done
because we think well maybe if i took
more satisfaction in the work that i
don't know if i felt if i felt like i
could take more of a break then that
might shortcut some of the things which
is propelling me to continue to do this
well when you start off
you have to work so damn hard
i mean i think that's something that is
not expressed enough to people is it
when you start off your cryptic a career
like mine you you you have to work so
damn hard in the beginning of my career
i didn't have a holiday for seven years
it was seven years until my family
persuaded me to go away with a holiday i
just couldn't go on holiday and one of
the reasons was
i at the at the beginning of my career
inevitably
if people called and asked me if i could
write something i had to do it
if
um i feared that if i said no
they wouldn't come back and ask again
now that's very common
the problem is there is a certain point
in your life when you have that fear and
it's no longer relevant
it's information that you're being told
by yourself about an earlier version of
yourself
and you have the right at a certain
point but it's very hard to make that
decision professionally
to say okay no i'm okay now i can take
time off i can say no this time
i can't turn that down well you also
need to you need to it's only in the
last 10 years that i learned how to say
no to things
because
i didn't know whether i'd be asked again
but as for
as for whatever the drive is underneath
that if i could
well i started self-revealing but
i suppose there are a couple of things
one is that i've always sought freedom
in my life
um
[Music]
as much freedom as i can have
and
some years ago i said to
my sort of friends and
some family members around and we're
talking about
various things
i said you know my experience of life
has been that
um
with every year i get more and more free
and i just realized i felt terrible
actually because i realized that a
younger guy who's there
said i i i don't feel that at all
he had exactly the opposite feeling and
i felt sort of terrible that i said this
um but it has sort of been my feeling is
that i've gone further and further in a
way i've gone further and further away
from home you might say
um
and
uh but that i've
wanted to be free and to pursue what i
want to pursue and to have the ability
to do that to write about what i want to
write about to go where i want to go
deliver i want to live and to be with
who i want to be with and this is
this is something i always
wanted and and various others british
journalist suzanne moore said something
quite similar in a piece on her
substance recently and i said to her i
said it just rang such a bell
uh so that's the first thing and i
suppose the second thing i could
probably point to is that
um
actually it's slightly i once said to my
late friend clive james and if you knew
a great australian polymath
i said to him towards the very end of
his life he was born in 1939
opening line of his memoirs it says you
know i was born in 1939 the other big
event that yeah um he's an amazing
wonderful man and but i remember saying
to him once you know about what do you
feel drives you and he lost his father
in the war he didn't die in the war he
lost his father died on the plane back
the americans like
brought some of the australian troops
back home early and the plane crashed
and
it was just clive and his mum then you
know and i remember
i said to cry once asked him about his
drive and he said i felt like i owed it
to the ruins of my family
um
i do have a sort of sense it's not to do
with family necessarily but
i do have a sense of being
born at a fortunate time
and having had
i don't say luck because i'm for reasons
i think you know i'm worried about the
term luck
but
i feel i have a good fortune which i
shouldn't waste
and you know
most of my predecessors predecessors of
my ancestors did not have very much
freedom
uh economic freedom
freedom to move around
freedom to find stuff out i mean i think
of
the libra you know the sort of the books
that would be on a shelf you know on
sort of grandparents age
relatives
you know they would have very small
numbers of books because people
other than intellectuals or
very rich people people didn't have very
many books you know
um
and i
always thought
if i can get the things that my
predecessors couldn't or go to places
they couldn't
why would i waste that
opportunity
um
you know can you imagine how frustrated
you'd be
to have been born in the
early 20th century or the late 19th
century
not able to leave your village really
even and
not knowing much about what even
happened in town you know or
let alone in the capital and
you know
and and with every generation
in a country like ours we've had the
ability to go further and further this
happened in my own family
and um
so i feel like it's the responsibility
not to waste that
um but more importantly i'm just driven
by the desire not to waste time you know
there's a line of andrew marvel
behind my back i always hear times
winged chariot hurrying near
i hear times winged chariot awfully loud
you spoke to me about instinct i can't
remember who it was that gave you a
piece of advice about how
sometimes it's wrong but at the time
it's the oh that that was clive as well
i just mentioned yeah i have a great
success on television and other things
but he um he once wrote a
he
he once wrote a verse play in rhyming
couplets about prince charles and opened
it in the west end in london it didn't
run for very long
i
think it closed before opening night i
think it i think it made it halfway
through opening night
i think it stopped at the interval
there's no one left including the cast
i
i remember devasta he was devastated
about it it was such a humiliating
career humiliation
um but he wrote somewhere i think he
said um
he said look i followed my instincts on
it and your instincts
don't always lead you right but you've
got to trust that they are the things
that have led you to what have been your
successes
and i've come to
to really follow that advice because
i've written about quite a bewildering
array of subjects in my life and written
books about a lot of different subjects
and
um
uh i sometimes
used to think
how can i be sure that it's gonna work
and the answer that comes back in my
head is you can't be sure
but you've been right before
so the odds of you being right again
are quite good
um
it's like
i find this thing interesting
if if if you wrote
about things you found interesting and
there was no reception for it
that would be one thing but if you say i
find this really quite interesting
and you write about it
and you get an audience
and then you write about something
totally different but it you find it
interesting
very often you find that's because other
people do too
and that's a fantastic thing as a writer
that's one of the best things is um is
is to be able to to do it not once but
quite a lot of times on different
subjects
because that means
that that you might have an ability to
and you obviously have this i mean you
have the ability to put your finger on
things
that are interesting to other people as
well
but that's
that's good news
where you said
instinct may sometimes direct you wrong
but it's the only thing which has ever
directed you right right and that's
a price that you need to pay for
following your instinct and you're right
you know this will be episode 900 or
something of this podcast in four years
uh which
is a
a workload that
is difficult to do on your own and um i
was i was reflecting after
our conversation about your seven years
without a
without a holiday i did
204 saturdays in a row at the same club
night without a break
every single saturday and
that was something similar and i there
is something uh
romantic
virtuous
heroic
old and worldy british
about
being someone that does the work in that
way perhaps it's perhaps it's a cult for
my puritan work ethic yes but we
probably both got a bit of that but i i
there's something about that that i like
i like the fact that i can look back
you know in whatever year's time when
there's a producer that comes in and
does everything when there's a team
that's looking after the editing or the
scheduling with the guests and i know
that i did
half a thousand or maybe a thousand of
them and it was all on my shoulders with
with a video guy back in the uk yeah
right and there's something beautiful
about that and
the other thing that i really adored
from when we spent time together in new
york that you told me about
was a story to do with regrets from
hitch
and this is a
we're talking about trade-offs here
right and this has been i wrote a
newsletter about it which i sent to you
and dude it is
it is one of the best
insights
for ameliorating regrets for
understanding that they're an
unavoidable part of our lives
um
you tell that story about yeah
about regrets yes chris richards he said
um
i think he wrote it in his memoir as
well he said uh
he said you have to choose your regrets
um
i mean everyone is going to have regrets
in their life you know
um
i know people who've achieved great
things and achieved
small things
all of them have regrets
[Music]
and yes you ha
you you have to know that
you're going to have regrets
and the question is which ones you can
bear
and which ones you don't think you can
bear
um
let me give you an obvious example
let's say you had a dream always of
starting a shop you know
you've got two options in front of you
really
one is
starting it
and seeing if it works
and the other one is
is not because you fear
that it won't work
you'll fall flat on your ass
um
both
both choices have regrets
and
the sort of person you are realize to a
great extent on
which one can i bear
can i bear
not having tried
but at least i didn't fail
more than i can bear
i tried
and i might have failed
either way in this this calculation
you're you are risking a type of regret
so you have to make the decision
um i have that all the time with writing
um
[Music]
quite a lot of times in my life um i've
written things
seriously against my own interests you
know
and
i have this
terrible tearing thing with inside
within me which is
i gotta say the thing i gotta say the
thing i just gotta say the thing don't
say the thing douglas don't say the
thing everyone's going to hate you uh
and i i'm going to say the thing
and
i know that it's because i have two
options in front of me one is one is
haven't i can't of all the details but
it happened not long ago politicians um
one is oh well that's that you know i've
broken that
relationship
and i i have that regret not that it's a
very big regret actually but um
but on the other hand i would have had
the regret of
i didn't say what i thought
so at least i don't have aragrad
um
but it is it is it is a profound insight
of christopher's because um
you know even freedom which i mentioned
earlier you know is not an unloyed
good it's not like searching for freedom
leads you only to a lack of regrets
um
i mean
my experience of freedom for yourself
can be very costly for others
the thing that it made me realize was
looking back i'd always presumed that
any regret that i had
was due to a sub-optimal decision that
i'd made right and that had i have been
able to go back
and make the right decision
i could have avoided regret entirely i
always thought
that regret was a bug
of my decision making not a feature an
inbuilt feature of being a human and as
soon as you realize the fact that look
opportunity cost exists by doing a thing
you're not doing another thing and even
if the thing that you chose to do was
perfectly accurate it was precisely the
right thing you're always going to have
an open loop around what could have
happened had i have done the other thing
so when you're given the choice between
two things
the the the a good way for anybody
that's stuck with the decision
is to think
which of these two choices could i not
bear to live with the regrettable
absolutely and that is clarified
absolutely that happens i mean i have
that thought all the time i mean all the
time
what what could i um
what could i not bear
um as i say for me a very strong one is
speaking my mind
speaking the truth as i see it i
couldn't bear not don't you
i would i find it very hard
um
um
you know an occasion as i say people say
to me
you should be a little bit more
diplomatic you know with this or you
should have been a bit easier on that
person
every elderly friend of mine often
phones me up and says oh that's another
country you can't visit
so there's about one place you can live
in the world
moving north korea no
no that's tough on them as well
unfairly you know
um
but but
yeah so so you you you work out what you
can't
what you
can't
you do realize i mean um
i mean this is a bit self-aggrandizing
but
there is also a difference in people of
the risk they're willing to take
which is
i don't over emphasize myself because
i'm a writer not a soldier
or a fireman or a policeman
um
but
i think there are
there are prices you pay
for throwing yourself against the world
and um
you have to decide whether you want to
pay them or not
most people go along with whatever
they're meant to go along with wherever
they are
and the certain type of person doesn't
and
generally speaking i think i tend to be
the sort of person who doesn't
and
that comes with
considerable
benefits in my case
freedom a certain degree of success and
so on
but it comes with a certain cost
i mean one of the costs is
um
you always feel a certain sense of
isolation you know
uh
not to say loneliness i don't feel like
i'm not lonely in any personal or
ideological sense but
but it's inevitable that if you don't go
along with the precepts
you're going to have a sort of
isolation
um
but then
even that i mean that you and then you
test that all the time
can i bear that
and
some of the time the answer will be no i
can't
so other times it'll be
yeah that's fine
and other times it'll be
i guess i have to
alanda says loneliness is a kind of tax
we have to pay to atone for a certain
complexity of mind
that's true that's true that's not bad
for allah um
uh yeah it's true
um but that's laid on top of or there's
a magnifying effect or a multiplier here
which is
the complexity of mind plus the decision
of whether or not to deploy this into
the real world
well again that depends on whether or
not your first forays
were received warmly or not
seth godin had this amazing insight
where he said uh a lot of the time we
need support but only the first time
around
that when you start to get some positive
reinforcement over time you can be you
can become more bone-headed you can
become more uh
singularly driven yes
but the first time can be
more
difficult to get through and i think
that's true
a more troubling one in a way is the one
that the older you get i'm now in my 40s
i'm 42 now but
um i was speaking musician friend the
other day who just
one of his
um
seniors that just died and
uh i know what was on my mind was on his
which is is
the fact that as you as you get older in
your
profession your career you you notice
the people who you looked to you
obviously thought were always going to
be there go
um
and then of course you have the
inevitable thing of
oh hell that's going to have to be
the position that's filled by
people of my
generation and
there's a responsibility that comes from
that there's also um
there's also
when you're starting off
hopefully you will have i certainly had
uh great mentors and
people i sought out
really
they didn't just get given to me i
sought them out to
help me start off
and
of course they die off
um
but then
they don't entirely because
that which got you started
is is is you become carries forward
within you yeah and
and so
it is a sort of eternal process of
it's what tom stoppard in arcadia
describes he says at one point something
like he says you know
the character um this is the the student
says um says to tutor something like she
says how can you cope with the fact that
all these players were lost in the
library at alexandria you know this
number by uh aesculus this number by
that how can you cope with all these
things that were lost and he says
because nothing is lost
nothing is lost to the march
he says the plays that were lost will
come back in fragments or
return again in another language
we shed as we pick up nothing's lost to
the march but all we have is the march
it's a constant process of loss and
renewal and discovery and loss and
rediscovery again
and
almost every profession i would have
thought is like that
being a writer is particularly like that
because you see the people who started
you off as they start to fall away
um
you have and keep certain things they
gave you
and there are for me at any rate
there are connections i feel to people
who i never met
through people i did know
and now
i feel quite often
uh
walking through a library or in a
bookshop or something
i feel like almost the whole place is
surrounded by friends somehow you know
oh i i think i knew him sometimes it is
something i know but
more often i give a connection to that
person
and
so the whole thing is a sort of
is a
is like a
a constant
rediscovery that's what that's what t.s
eliot saw it as
it's like
i'm sorry i sound like i'm waffling but
i'm coming to a major point i promise
um
there's a version of uh
history and ideas that
is
um
common at the moment which is endless
progress
and i never really believed in that just
innately i didn't think that things were
always getting better i always thought
it was all up for grabs i don't know why
i always thought that but i did
even the people who believed in the sort
of fukiyama stuff
you had to have
bart about two world wars
those are two quite big footnotes you
know to a theory
but the theory of progress is
most people including people i meet
grown-ups all the time who believe in it
everything's always just getting better
inevitably
um and they think that art and other
things goes along an inevitable path
getting better and better bigger and
bigger clearer and clearer
more and more accomplished but there's
another way of seeing things which is
the one i've just been trying to outline
which is
that it's actually cyclical the whole
thing
that things
are lost and come around again
and that's that's the case with ideas
for sure
i mean
whole libraries
die every day in the heads of people
and
they will hopefully be reborn in another
head
the same day
um
goethe says somewhere um
in one of his poems about the
the need to recreate that which has been
created
and i think that's one of the great
noble enterprises which is to recreate
that which has been created
to rediscover that which has been
as early but it lost and found and lost
again and again
and everything's like that
all the time wisdom is being lost
but hopefully it's being picked up again
by someone else
you know every time you lose you lose
somebody irreplaceable
and they're not replaced but somebody
else steps in
and
that's the march
douglas murray ladies and gentlemen the
war on the west will be linked in the
show notes below
where else should people go if they want
to keep up to date with what you're
doing
you can find me on instagram a little
bit
um
twitter douglas k murray
find me in the new york post the sun the
spectator
and various other platforms
douglas i appreciate you thank you it's
a great pleasure
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace